grazie presidente
honorable members
i come to parliament today to
report on our plans for the next
european council
on december 10th and 11th but
before i turn to that please allow me to
update you
on two issues that will certainly also
be topic
on the european council it's about
brexit
and about the situation we are facing
with respect to the
mff and next generation eu
honourable members these are decisive
days
for our negotiations with the united
kingdom
but frankly i cannot tell you today
if in the end there will be a deal
there has been genuine progress on a
number of important questions
on law enforcement and judicial
cooperation
on social security coordination
and also on goods on services and
transport
we now have an outline of a possible
final text
in these areas there are still some
important issues to agree
but they should be manageable however
there are still three issues that can
make the difference between a deal and
no deal the crucial topics for the
european side
are of course questions linked to the
level playing field
the governance and fisheries
and with very little time ahead of us
we will do all in our power to reach an
agreement
we're ready to be creative but we are
not
ready to put into question the integrity
of the single market
the main safeguard for european
prosperity and wealth
and this is why we need to establish
robust
mechanisms ensuring that competition
is and remains free and fair
over time in the discussions about state
aid
we have still serious issues for is for
instance when it comes to enforcement
significant difficulties remain on the
question
how we can secure now and over time
our common high standards on labor on
social rights
on the environment the climate change
and tax
transparency no you know all these
standards
we want to know what remedies are
available
in case one side will deviate in the
future
because trust is good but law
is better and crucially
in the light of recent experience a
strong
governance system is essential to ensure
that what has been agreed is actually
done
concerning fisheries no one questions
the uk sovereignty in its own waters
but we ask for predictability
and guarantees for fishermen and fisher
women
who have been sailing in these waters
for
decades if not centuries
honorable members as i said the next
days are going to be decisive
the european union is well prepared for
a no
deal scenario but of course we prefer to
have an agreement
i fully trust in the skillful steer
of our chief negotiator michel barnier
but one thing is clear whatever the
outcome
there has to be and there will be a
clear difference
between being a full member of the union
and being just a valued partner
i am fully aware of the challenges the
current situation is creating especially
for the parliament and the ratification
process
and this is why i sincerely thank
for your support and your understanding
as in the past we will walk those
last miles together
[Music]
honorable members this is especially the
case
as the pandemic situation remains
serious
with nearly 3 000 deaths a day
covet 19 was the cause number one
for death in the eu last week
hospitals remain under stress and
in some regions intensive care units are
overwhelmed
i know that shop owners bartenders and
waiters and restaurants
want an end to restrictions but we
must learn from the summer and not
repeat
the same mistakes relaxing too fast
and too much is a risk for third wave
after christmas weeks ago
i've said that this christmas will be
different
and yes it will be quieter
and this is also a question of
solidarity between member states
but there is also good news the european
commission by now has secured contracts
on vaccines with six pharmaceutical
companies
the first european citizens might
already be vaccinated before the end of
december
and there's finally light at the end of
the tunnel
and yes as i've said vaccines are
important
but what counts is vaccinations
member states must get ready now we're
talking about millions of syringes we're
talking about cold chain we're talking
about
organizing vaccination centers we're
talking about trained personnel that is
there
you name it all this has to be prepared
in short member states have to prepare
the logistics
for the deployment of hundreds of
millions of doses of vaccines
because this is our ticket out of the
pandemic
honourable members whether covet or not
there is another crisis that rumbles on
global warming the crisis of our planet
and honorable members
a growing number of countries have
pledged carbon neutrality by 2050
good news i firmly believe we must all
put a price on carbon
these words could have been mine but
they're not
these are remarks of antonio guterres
secretary general of the united nations
at the g20 summit last weekend
for the first time since four years
the g20 agreed on clear commitments
for the fight against climate change and
europe has been proudly leading the way
by now more than half of the g20
members have committed to climate or
carbon neutrality
around twenty fifty it demonstrates
that being courageous pays off
and it shows that we have chosen the
right course
when we decided to cut back co2
emissions
until 2030 by at least 55 percent
this should also encourage the heads of
states and government
to confirm this goal at the next
european council
but there's only so much we can do when
members states
do not put into practice what they agree
upon
for example the strong rules again
against money laundering
and terrorist financing or against the
use of firearms
implementation is key and i'm sure
the european council will be an
opportunity
to turn to action quickly
honourable members from brexit to the
fight against the pandemic
from the budget to the fight against
terrorists
it is when we manage to join forces
that we europeans can achieve the most
it is when we negotiate heart and then
stick to the compromise
found that we move forward best
this is how we will finally leave the
corona world
and continue to build our future langley
europa long live europe liver of mercy
[Applause]
[Music]
um